Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: No playing Chicken!
Playing "chicken" is defined as a test of
courage in which two parties engage in mutual
challenges, waiting for the other person to
back down first.
Dr. Bright's version of chicken tends to involve
climbing onto SCP-682's back, daring one of
his colleagues to climb atop another dangerous
SCP, and ride them toward each other to "see
what happens."
This is strictly prohibited, and Dr. Bright
is no longer allowed to play Chicken with
any department at the Foundation.
Don't say yes if he asks you to play chicken.
Don't even agree if he offers you some fried
chicken.
Who knows what he's up to?